welcome back to pg chain design this is
pj today we are going to talk about how
to do the 3d model on this eternity ring
with the share prong holding for the
stone are you ready let's get started
[Music]
before we starting this tutorial i
wanted to understand that in between the
stone
the gap in between the stone it's better
in between 0.1 to 0.2 millimeter you
don't want to get it too far because
this don't need to reflect each other
you don't want to get way too close
because it may crack the stone when you
set it all right that's starting from a
scratch you can download this roundstone
at the link in the description below
sign up the newsletter then you will get
a link for this stone so that's starting
with the front view and and i would like
to have the ring size for 16 millimeter
and then you can moving up and down
whatever close the stone or not one
thing you want to keep in mind that you
don't want to have the point which is
the coolant of the stone getting too
close to inside of a ring because if you
set it a little bit lower it might get
past
and scratch the finger ideally you want
to have at least 0.5 millimeter there
all right the second thing i wanted to
do is i want to creating a ring shank
first so let me go ahead to use the um
rectangle and then you have the one it's
called conic corners because i like this
more like a comfort fit there so i'm
going to draw something look like this
and moving this one by using the move
command cement snapping into the
quadrant to the quadrant right there we
can change it later after we put the
stone
in place and overall looking to make it
longer or shorter so we want to use the
command for sweep one rail this is the
rail this is the cross section and make
sure you record a history so we can
change it later if we want to all right
so now we have the stone a little bit
sticking into this uh the part that's
okay you can always punch the hole later
all right the second thing is we need to
creating uh the stone all the way around
in this case i would like to have the
stone be select and we're gonna use the
command for polar array and then we
wanna snapping into the zero i'm going
to try 20 and see how that work and it's
actually pretty good for 20 there the
gap is not too big it's not too small
it's not jamming each other so i'm going
to click okay there so this will be my
stone now that's starting working on the
prong ideally i'm just going to draw
something really quick here
for the reference first of all
if my prong is going to starting from
here i want to end it about right here
you don't need to end it like too tall
and then so that's a reference there so
i'm gonna using the arc tool this is a
art start endpoint on the arc and we
wanted to snapping into the end point
right here endpoint right here and i
want to give it the really grays for arc
looking there and that was a reference
line so we can delete it now if we are
looking at this arc right here you can
see it's it's about like a re it's it's
on a construction plane right so
basically i want to move it up a little
bit because i don't want to go taper all
the way to the center and i also wanted
to rotate it so i'm going to rotate this
guy and moving about this spot right
here it's roughly right in the middle
that's the ideal
position that i wanted to have let's
give it a try by using the pipe command
and let's pipe it for
0.4 millimeter as a radius and let's see
how it works ideally you want this prong
end it up right in the middle so then it
can be the shear prong there all right
if that look good to you let's go ahead
to mirror that to the other side and see
if that on the side view if see if that
is the right place you want him to be
all right so if that is the right place
you want him to be let me group this one
we're going to coming over to the front
view and then let's go ahead to use the
the same command for the polar array we
had that 20 stone there so we wanted 20
this item as well and then you will see
this is connected each other double make
sure that if where it is connected is
look alright it is connected to the
bottom of the ring shank if it is like
too close so not touching the stone uh
having this like a double shadow it's
not hundred percent uh together that's
fine because after the setting you will
need to file this unless you are doing
for the rendering purpose then you will
need to make sure that it is 100
matching all right once you have that
i'm going to group this one all i need
to do is mirror to the other side so
let's go ahead to mirror and it will get
something like this all right so the
eternity ring is done one thing keep in
mind this type of a ring is so hard to
size if you want to size up and down
like half size it's almost impossible
because all the stone is arranged nicely
right so make sure that you got this uh
ring size corrected before you building
your model all right the next things i
wanted to do is having a small stone
right at that triangle area so what i
like to do picking up this stone and i'm
going to move it to the side using the
gumball hit the alt key and then you
were making a copy and then you'll get
something like this all right and also
with this one i want it to be smaller
and maybe it's a little bit taper
like this all right
now with this one maybe you need to move
it a little bit lower
right
we need to creating the prong as well so
i'm going to create a prong about
this size and
using the pipe tool to creating the
radius maybe
0.25
and to create our first prong here all
right
you wanted to cutting into the stone
just a little bit less than 25 percent
will be ideal and then i also want this
prong to be making a copy so that's
coming into the front view i want to
have a one copy about right here and the
other one i'm simply just going to
mirror to the other side all right and
double make sure this look good to you
and
i think his stone is a bit a little bit
too big so i'm going to moving this one
down moving this one right there i
always like to just mirror to the other
side to be more symmetrical so i'm going
to pick up this one
and mirror to the other side all right
prong size is not changing just the
stone size because fitting into that
small hole it might be too big then i
would like to pick up
all four object and group them right
instead of moving like this the angle
won't be right i would like to use the
rotate tool
and i'm going to snapping into the zero
and i'm going to move it like this
all right so this will helping you to
get angle is more correct i may need to
move it down but because the angle is
already right so i can just using the
gumball to move it let's take a look on
the side all right
now we wanted to move it inside just
using the gumball to drag it and see if
that is the right place over there all
right
now
what i'm looking at here i think the
prong is a little bit too tall so i'm
going to ungroup it and just bring in
those two prong because it's tapered a
little bit that taper is tilted a little
bit so that might need to get inside a
little bit more i'm going to group it
one more time and maybe
to look like it's like cutting inside
too much maybe i need to move it out a
little bit and this prong need to be
moving in a little bit stick it out too
much
all right that will make sure everything
look okay to you so that's also group it
coming back to the front view let's go
ahead to
using the polar array again we need 20
of them and then that will be one side
and let's just go ahead to pick up
everybody and mirror to the other side
then we'll have it done like that that
will make sure if the render look okay
all right more stone setting information
you can check out my online course for
stone setting 3d modeling course on my
website thank you for watching and i
will see you next
[Music]
you